outside the dance studio where a
massacre took place a moment of
reflection
this is a predominantly Asian Community
experiencing the most American of
tragedies
one man with a very powerful gun able to
end 11 lives in a matter of seconds
for many this dance floor was an
extended family those killed were in
their 50s 60s and 70s the first victim
identified as 65 year old my my nan
Jenny and Selena have been coming here
for years their best friend was shot
dead inside I think maybe he's in the
middle of the dancing and then uh you
know and then he he was happened to be
in front of the door I think that's what
it is because he he didn't he passed
away right there I cannot even describe
how nice he is how difficult of the last
few days been for you knowing what's
happened here very difficult I I cannot
I try myself not to think about it but
if I think about it I become very
emotional
after leaving the Star Dance Studio the
gunman drove along these roads around 10
minutes to the nearby city of Alhambra
it was there that he headed to another
Dance Studio
detectives believe he would have
continued his Killing Spree here at the
lylai dance hall if the owner's son
hadn't wrestled the gun from him at the
entrance at one point I was able to pull
the gun away from him shove him aside
create some distance
point the gun at him intimidate him shot
him and say
get the hell out here I'll shoot get
away the gunman was 72 year old who can
Tran officers are investigating whether
some victims were targeted as part of a
domestic dispute seven of the Wounded
are still in hospital many of the
middle-aged and older people who came
here have pledged to return to the dance
floor but the healing will take time